bueno como analista de interpretación
hace usted de la decisión de rusia de
reducir sus tropas en las cercanías de
la frontera con ucrania es un paso
efectivo para destrabar el conflicto
claro por supuesto las exigencias que
rusia ha venido haciendo en torno a este
conflicto primero lo más básico para
ello que desprender un documento
jurídico vinculante de la otan en el
cual se complementa que no va a ser
atacado el otro por supuesto es la
autonomía de las dos provincias
separatistas que quiere putin que se
acordaron en el famoso encuentro de
mills en la reunión de bits donde se
establecieron los parámetros posteriores
a el 2014 cuando él tomó justamente
crimea allá lo necesita muy claro y es
que
es que la guerra santa y la guerra para
rusia no es conveniente porque no es
conveniente la guerra porque esto
ahogaría económicamente a rusia ahogaría
económicamente a putin y prácticamente
eso lo estaría sacando de la arena
internacional qué significa esto la
oposición se le vendría en su email y al
venirse en la oposición a putin encima
tendrían todos los problemas del mundo
no solamente en la misma
en la misma
rusia sino también con los satélites con
los socios estratégicos que tiene putin
en el mundo llámese de cuba llámese
venezuela así estás básicamente de las
cosas a santiago ahora moscú se retira
parcialmente y advierte que no quiere
una guerra en europa pero por otra parte
eeuu asegura que el ataque todavía es
posible incluso dijeron que podría darse
esta misma semana cómo interpretar qué
conclusiones sacar de estos
protagonistas del conflicto con
declaraciones tan antagónicas
bueno mira yo he venido asegurando en
todos los medios internacionales en cnn
en todas las cadenas mundiales de
televisión en univision ha dicho siempre
lo mismo y es que lo que pasa es que
conociendo el carácter de los rusos como
lo conozco sé que putin simplemente está
presionando metiendo el pedal al fondo
para ver qué tanto provecho le saca de
toda esta situación es que ahí es donde
está precisamente la clave de toda esta
situación mírate cuántos soldados colocó
en torno a ucrania estamos hablando en
la frontera del este estamos hablando la
frontera norte y todo lo que tenía en el
mar también sea el que ha hecho un cerco
a ucrania de tal manera que ha obligado
a europa hay dos factores aquí en juego
un y string 2 que es el tubo es la
tubería y solo el reducto por el cual se
le va a llevar el combustible alemania
presionando de esta manera alemania al
que también entra en juego y defienda
los intereses de rusia en esta en este
asunto está el presidente más cron que
ha llegado tu saber hacia una pasada a
moscú y obviamente ha traído un
documento a putin hecho por supuesto por
lo tanto en el cual pues ellos la
establecen las condiciones con las
cuales podrían negociar con él
otro factor importante es la pérdida de
vidas humanas y en el primer día 23 días
de combate se perderían más de 50.000
vidas civiles por estos tiempos de
bombardeo o sea esto es algo que no le
conviene y posiblemente si este
conflicto o santiago podría arrastrar
toda europa a enfrentarse al mismo putin